thank you I'm super excited to be here
today I want to start by telling you a
story in this story is Jake Jake's the
software engineer and he's currently
working on an ambitious new web
application and he and his team are
super excited about the project however
as often happens it's a few weeks behind
schedule and they just had to spend a
long week wrapping up the key feature
now it's a Monday and Jake is feeling
extra worn out because he had to deal
with some family problems over the
weekend he would really like a day off
but he doesn't have any PTO when he
knows that the rest of his team is hard
at work so he decides to tough it out
and head into the office the first thing
he does when he gets there is check on
that poll work less you up and on Friday
he sees he got a review and wants to
check the comments on it but it turns
out there was only one comment and it
was left by a senior engineer on his
team and it says this won't work that's
it nothing else so then since he started
out pretty tired Jake's already
beginning to feel some frustration he's
thinking to himself well why won't this
work it is what was asked in I worked
hard on it but he moves on he has a
meeting coming up it's his first meeting
of the day and it's a one-on-one with
his manager he gets to the meeting a bit
early hoping that he'd be able to have
some time to talk about his frustrations
and some problems going on with the
project but as soon as his manager gets
to the door he asks Sam have you
finished feature X this feature was
supposed to be delivered last week but
due to issues with other teams he was
then able to finish it on time and so
they spend their whole time discussing
that
so when Jake leaves this meeting he's
thinking to himself no it's not finished
but that's not what I wanted to talk
about so it's about lunchtime now and he
heads to lunch with his teammates since
his meeting ran a bit long though by the
time he gets to the lunch table they're
already in conversation Jake's hoping
that they could talk about something
other than tech for a little bit and
seeing as it is on Monday he's hoping
that maybe they have some weekend
stories that they could share
however they're already in conversation
and they're talking about the latest
JavaScript framework did you hear about
new thing Jas Jade hasn't heard of this
because he was dealing with family
issues over the weekend and so he's
thinking to himself great yet another
thing that I need to go learn this feeds
into is already negative emotions about
the day there's so much going on for him
there's too much going on so it's after
lunch now and Jake really just wants to
go home so he soaks back to his death
desking kind of just fires up his text
editor he can't quite get into flow with
his work and so he checks his emails and
checks Twitter a bunch and kind of just
sits there quietly until the clock
finally hits 5:00 and he feels okay I've
put in a full day I can go home so how
many of you have ever had a day of like
Jake chips did a day where you feel
tired and worn out and like no one's
really supporting you and the
frustrations are having that work I know
I have Jake's story here is similar to
parts of my own story and I imagine
they're similar to many stories that
could be shared in this audience my name
is Trent Willis and I'm a senior UI
engineer at Netflix apparently and today
I want to talk about a skill that I
believe is really really important for
our industry but often crew crucially
undervalued that is the ability to care
for your fellow developers you see the
tragic thing about the story with Jake
is that this one disappointing and
discouraging day can easily turn into
weeks or months of feeling worn out at
work this means lost productivity lower
team morale and potentially if things
are bad enough the loss of a talented
employee so how can things have gone
differently how could the interactions
that have occurred between Jake and his
co-workers have been made better without
them knowing what was going through
Jake's mine aren't necessarily going on
in Jake's personal life that's what
we're gonna explore for the remainder of
this talk so to start I want us to focus
on this first word caring in context
it's an action it's not a state of being
but something which you perform
in speaking with other developers and
managers I've often found that we talk
about caring or empathy and high-level
or abstract terms we don't really speak
frequently about the actions which we
think represent someone caring and even
less do we talk about how there's
applied to people that aren't in
leadership positions the good news here
though is that since caring is an action
it means that there are some specific
acts and thought processes we can employ
to be more caring and since there are
actions that means we can practice them
and if we can practice them that means
we can get better at them and it also
means that we can work at them together
and work with each other to improve so
now's a good time for me to mention that
I'm not a caring person by nature I am
an introvert in that I get drained from
interacting with other people so being
supportive especially in emotionally
hard times is really difficult
additionally I can have a hard time
relating to others at points and often
like to keep to myself I'm sure at least
some of you know what this is like
however I've been tremendously lucky to
have wonderful people in my life
especially in the workplace that have
called me out on how I interact with
co-workers and encourage me to be better
at it to strive to be better so now I
look at it this way
I respect my limitations but I don't use
them as an excuse and what I mean by
this is I know that I'm gonna have to
put in a little extra bit of effort in
order to be more caring and supportive
of my teammates but that's no reason for
me not to do it we're all humans first
in developers second and I definitely
put in lots of effort and energy towards
being a better developer so it's only
reasonable that I can put in at least
some effort towards being a better
person and a more caring teammate so
with that in mind let's look at some
practical ways that we can get better at
caring together
so first up code reviews whether it's
product reviews code reviews or design
reviews the process of soliciting
feedback about decisions and then
incorporating that feedback is a
relatively regular part of most
developers work now there's a lot that
we can say
about how to make code reviews more more
caring how we can be more caring in
those actions invited he covered a lot
of that in our talk earlier but I really
just want to focus on one area that is
the emotional and interpersonal aspects
of these review processes in a written
version of her talk she groups these
under a header called the harder things
but the most important which leaves us
with the question why are these the
harder things and why are they the most
important things it's because they're
almost entirely of all about people or
more specifically they're about people
and communication and so whether it's
communication in the form of feedback or
critiques or even just a discussion
about the way something was done
communication between a reviewer and
overview II is really the Avenue by
which these reviews derive their value
if I leave a comment that's just LG TM
looks good to me that doesn't really
tell you a whole lot right like what's
good about it or did you even really
look at it like if you don't have
anything specific to say how do I know
that you actually looked at it and so
with this in mind how can we incorporate
more care into our communication process
well there's a lot of things we can do
and I don't plan to try to solve the
entire gamut of interpersonal
communication problems in a 20 minute
talk but I want to focus on one specific
area and that is your tone so whether
it's a review or an email or any form of
written communication we really need to
make sure that we're not being tone deaf
what I mean by this is be cognizant of
the tone that you're using when you're
communicating we've all or most of us
have likely at one point or another
interacted with someone that is it a
condescending detached or just negative
in the way that they communicate and
just as those tones can be really
draining and reviews in written
communication they're also draining a
normal conversation so we need to be
conscious that we're not letting the
fact that we're sitting behind a
computer translate into the way that
we're communicating to our co-workers
through that computer which can often
happen but to illustrate why I
tone is such an important part of our
jobs I want to share a brief story so a
little while ago I was working on a
project and it was supported by a really
skilled infrastructure team the
developers on the main project would
defer to this infrastructure or support
team frequently because they had a lot
of experience and expertise however some
members of this m4 team could come
across as a bit condescending or aloof
especially when reviewing the code of
developers that Warnock's experienced so
what resulted is that the developers
working on this project began to avoid
the zimpher team and this led to
problems in the project problems that
probably could have been avoided had
they had the insight of these more
experienced developers and so the
outcome here was that the project was
negatively and directly impacted by the
communication style of just a couple
members of this team it wasn't even the
whole team just some of them and this
impacted not only the project but also
relationships and the team's morale in
the long run so what can you do to make
sure that things like this don't happen
well to start if you've never really put
thought into how you communicate in the
tone that you're conveying ask your
co-workers it can either be about review
specifically or more generally about how
you communicate I can almost guarantee
you that they would have something to
say to you beyond that ask them what
they think that you can do to improve in
doing this you're opening up a dialogue
for you guys to figure out how to work
better and more effectively together but
it's also important to realize that this
isn't going to be something that you do
once and you're done with it different
teams and different individuals within a
team are all going to have different
communication styles and you need to
work together to find ways to improve
that communication this will let you
collaborate more effectively grow closer
as a team and avoid frustration and
misunderstanding so beyond soliciting
this feedback though I also have a set
of guidelines that I keep to help me
keep my tone in check while I'm
communicating those are ask questions
often explain frequently and never
decree
so by asking questions we're
acknowledging the rationality and
intelligence of the other person at the
end of the review by explaining we share
context and provide opportunities for
others joining the conversation to learn
and then might not de cream we avoid
coming across as condescending and out
of touch with the experiences of other
developers which is often what it feels
like so if we apply these guidelines how
might the review comment from the
beginning of Jake's day have looked well
instead of saying this won't work and
leaving it at that its coworker may have
instead chosen to say why did you
approach it this way I'm not sure this
will work because and then engine insert
is rationale so this approach to several
things first it acknowledges that Jake's
a rational and logical and intelligent
person he likely had reasons for why he
chose to approach the problem the way
that he did second it gives an
opportunity for the reviewer to share
context that Jake might be missing as to
why this won't work or on the other hand
it will allow Jake to see where the
reviewer is missing context that Jake
had while implementing the future and
then finally it shows that there was
time and care put into reviewing Jake's
hard work and not just being a drive by
where he left a flippant comment and so
the only real drawback here is that I
will have taken the review or slightly
more time to construct his review
comment but really putting in that a
little bit of time is the bare necessity
that we should be asking of someone
reviewing code that is going to be going
to production now there's a whole lot
more I could say about communication and
code reviews or reviews in general but
I'll end this section with one more tip
about improving their tone and that is
make opportunities for praise what I
mean by this is there are chances for
you to encourage and support and be
positive even when you have to provide
fatigues or potentially disagree with
someone if nothing else simply drop in a
comment like great job or thanks for all
the hard work on this just do that from
time to time a little bit of positivity
can go a long way
constant barrage
of technical comments in critiques and
feedback can be really draining to
everyone involved but sending some
positivity can really help restore that
energy for someone that's having to be
reviewed this goes doubly so if you're a
senior or a lead engineer because that
means there is probably someone looking
up to you and as such you should be
setting an example for how to be
supportive of your teammates
so moving on Jake had a slightly less
than stellar encounter in a one-on-one
meeting with his manager now this
meeting didn't necessarily need to be
with his manager could have been with a
co-worker up here a mentor or anyone
really but the fact that it was his
manager carried extra weight for Jake
but we also have to remember that Jake's
manager probably wasn't trying to be
malicious here
he just wanted a status update and given
the circumstances he was likely under a
lot of pressure to deliver as well so if
we step into the shoes of Jake's manager
here how can we make sure that we're
being supportive while meeting with
someone else well the first thing that
we should do is try to be flexible with
our time in one-on-one meetings that
means that this is someone that you meet
with relatively regularly or are going
to be meeting regularly it's important
to acknowledge that you're meeting with
someone else and so while you may be
coming to this meeting with a bunch of
objectives and ideas about what you want
to get out of it the person you're
meeting with is also coming with
expectations about what they want to get
out of it and so as a leader or as
someone that's leading a one-on-one then
you should practice being flexible with
your time if they have something
important that they want to discuss make
sure that you make some room for it if
you have something absolutely critical
that needs to be discussed with them
though perhaps that should be another
meeting a different meeting from your
one-on-one this idea of being flexible
with your time ties into a concept of
psychological safety so back in 2012
Google did a study called Project
Aristotle that was aimed at discovering
what made certain teams more effective
than others they researched over a
hundred teams in over several years and
that psychological safety was a key
indicator of effective teams but what
does that mean
what is psychological safety well in the
field of psychology it's a group trait
that's marked by behaviors such as
conversational turn-taking
and high average social sensitivity now
if you're like me and not a psychologist
you might be thinking okay that doesn't
make anything any more clear so put more
plainly it's a sense that your group or
your team will not embarrass reject or
punish you for speaking up so how does
this tie into one-on-ones well as a as
someone that's hosting on one-on-one it
means that you have some level of
influence and as someone with influence
it's your responsibility to help create
a psychologically safe workplace for
your co-workers and so if you are
allowing them to be able to come to you
and feel confident that you will listen
in your one-on-one meetings by being
flexible with your time then it will go
a long way toward setting an example for
them to feel comfortable speaking up in
all circumstances because they know that
they value your voice and that they
value your ability to have opinions and
thoughts so beyond ensuring that your
team feels comfortable speaking up
though you also need to make sure that
you're hearing what they aren't
explicitly telling you so there's a
quote by management guru Peter F Drucker
that says the most important thing in
communication is hearing what isn't said
now this quote is often used to talk
about nonverbal communication but I
believe that it's also applicable to
verbal communication you see if
someone's if you hear a bunch of
developers complaining about a problem
but they're not explicitly asking for it
to be resolved you can still guess that
there's something that needs to be done
there or maybe it's not that obvious
maybe you see a co-worker who's every
time you talk to him is sounds really
frustrated but you don't know why but
you do know that he's been staying late
at work a lot recently in both of these
cases you can identify ways to help or
to care for your teammates and the first
scenario where you're hearing developers
complain escalate the problem
someone that can go fix it for them or
if you're not sure how big of an issue
it is go talk to the developers and be
pointed about figuring out if this is a
true problem for them and the latter
scenario where your co-workers being
frustrated go talk to him see if you can
take on some of the work or if you don't
have the bandwidth to do that go find
his manager and ask him hey can we get
more developers to help this guy out so
he doesn't have to stay late or hey can
we get more or we can we change the
expectations on when these things need
to be delivered so that way he doesn't
feel all this pressure the point is is
that if you stop and look there are
likely things going on in your team that
could be made better if someone took the
time to notice them so let's consider
Jake's earlier meeting instead of asking
about feature acts right away what if
his manager had started their meeting by
asking by saying I have something I'd
like to talk about but first is there
anything that you would like to talk
about this way Jake knows that there's
an opportunity there for him to talk
about his frustrations especially if
there's something that's really weighing
on him it's important that his manager
doesn't say something like I have
something very important that I want to
talk about because if he does that then
Jake may be like well am i my problems
really that important maybe they can
wait on the flip side of this coin
though Jake needs to recognize that
there is something his manager wants to
talk about and so if they use up all
their time in the meeting talking about
Jake's frustrations then they should
schedule another meeting
Jake should offer this carrying goes
both ways and it's up to both parties to
recognize this now he might question at
this point if this always makes sense
right what if the manager has a really
critical business topic that's blocking
another team or what if Jake's
frustrations can't be resolved well
you'll need to use your best judgment I
mean as with most things in software
engineering there's no one solution to
everything but be careful because small
problems and small frustrations have a
habit of snowballing and turning into
much larger issues now there's plenty
more that I could talk about in terms of
meetings in building effective
one-on-one meetings
but I want to end this section with one
more tip let us go for a walk if you've
never done it before try taking a walk
during our one-on-ones anecdotally
speaking they can feel a lot more
relaxed and laid-back than sitting in a
cold conference room across from someone
and especially if you have something
difficult to discuss it can be a lot
easier to do that while you're looking
at your feet or looking at the beautiful
scenery around you instead of sitting in
a cold conference room staring into
someone's eyes that said make sure that
you take into account the person you're
meeting with this won't work for
everyone and so you should communicate
with each other to find a structure that
is effective and useful for both of you
so we've now talked about two specific
work-related tasks that come up but what
about other day-to-day activities if
you're a developer chances are you don't
spend your whole day in meetings or
doing code reviews well at least I
should hope not so how do you care for
your teammates if you're just getting
lunch or chatting about tech or simply
doing a lull in the day at your desks
well my first tip here is to close the
shop as high-performing and really
motivated individuals it can be really
easy for us to want to talk about work
or talk shop all the time and especially
in the tech industry I've met tons of
people especially at conferences like
this that love what they do and love
their jobs and that is fantastic I'm
super happy about that but if that's all
that I ever know about people then I'm
missing out on critical opportunities to
build memories and stronger bonds and
connections with my teammates
that means we're missing out on chances
to build more collaborative teams that
can work more effectively together and
therefore deliver better products in the
end so we should inquire about family
and friends ask about their hobbies talk
about local events or maybe even ask
them about their favorite Netflix series
the possibilities really are almost
endless so if we think about Jake's
earlier lunch conversation what if
instead of say talking about new thing
JSL lunches co-workers opened up by
talking about know what everyone had
done over the weekend maybe jake would
have a chance to open up about how he's
feeling with the project
if his co-workers are feeling the same
way they can commiserate about it or if
he feels that's too personal he can
always sit back and hear about what's
going on in the lives of his co-workers
and find a way to connect with him that
way now this isn't to say that you
should never talk about work especially
if you enjoy work outside of the office
but it is to say that try to put naam
work things at the forefront every now
and then so I guess more accurately
instead of closing the shop close the
shop occasionally don't shut it down
permanently and I think you'll be
surprised by how easy it is to find
other things to talk about once you
begin to understand your co-workers
apart from their role at the office and
those close this goes a long way towards
helping build a psychologically safe
workplace because it's letting your
co-workers know that hey you have value
to me outside of the function that
you're fulfilling it while you're in the
office so at this point it could feel
like I'm prescribing a bunch of steps or
a bunch of things that you have to do
checkboxes to check in order to build a
caring and effective team but that's not
really the goal my goal in this talk is
to provide examples examples of how we
translate this amorphous concept of
caring or being empathetic and turn them
into concrete actions that we can think
about in practice or start incorporating
into the work life so I think author Bob
goft expressed the idea that for me lies
behind all of this really succinctly in
a book that he has called love does and
he says you don't need a plan you just
need to be present what does it mean to
be present in this context though well
it's not really so much about a specific
moment or a location in time it's about
the environment in the workplace setting
that you find yourself in your teammates
in there's this intersection of yourself
and the unique personalities of your
teammates and your work circumstances
that is really the present moment for
you so being present allows you to see
how the review comment you're about to
leave might be interpreted negatively by
your teammate or it will allow you to
see that the person you're meeting with
is looking worn out and
needs a break and it also lets you
recognize when your team is ready to
celebrate a victory and this that last
item is really important because it
would be really easy to get the idea
from this talk that caring only matters
when bad stuff is happening analysis but
that's not true accomplishments
victories celebrations they all need to
be shared because otherwise if you're
only around when bad stuff is happening
to your coworkers are there looking
stressed out and you're basically just a
bad omen and that's not a good team pain
so remember how Jake just kind of soaked
back to his desk after lunch we've all
likely seen co-workers in the similar
situation whether it's increased sighing
or longer stares off into space or maybe
more cursing or abnormal quietness
they're usually signs when people are
feeling off or feeling down about what's
going on in their job being present and
actively giving them some attention from
time to time allows us to recognize when
people look off that's really important
now when we recognize people look off
though it's really easy for us to think
oh I'm just gonna pretend that doesn't
exist and ignore it because it's
comfortable like we don't want to get
involved in other people's mess however
I would encourage you to take a deep
breath and then lean in and simply ask
him hey are you doing okay is there
anything you want to talk about or maybe
make it a bit more personal I don't know
hey you've been a bit more quiet than
usual hey is everything okay sometimes
that's all it takes to turn someone's
day or entire we compound just knowing
that someone wants to listen they may
not necessarily open up so don't push it
they don't have to tell you anything but
let them know that you're there and that
you care and you're available so as a
brief example of this one of the closest
co-workers I ever had loved Martinelli's
apple juice as do I but they didn't
stock it in the building that we worked
in I know this is a Silicon Valley
problem but they stopped it in a
building across our campus and so we
would often go for some walks to get
some apple juice on this walk which only
a couple of minutes was a chance for us
to talk openly about whatever we wanted
without fear of other people being
around we could vent if we were really
frustrated about something or we could
talk enthusiastically about something
the point is that there was always an
open invitation there to talk but there
was never an expectation and that
difference between expectation and
invitation is really important because
there is a sense that hey I have someone
I can go to if I need but I can also
keep to myself if I want it has an
introvert that's really important
because I think my privacy so all of
this leads me to my final word of advice
that is be available and be open when I
asked a group of managers and developers
what they thought a developer should do
to be a more caring and more empathetic
teammate almost half of them said
something along the lines of be
available for your teammates and be open
when you respond to them the reasoning
here is that being available makes you
really approachable and can help you
build relationships with your teammates
if you're never around or never at your
desk and people don't know how to get
ahold of you then it may come across as
if you're too busy you're too important
for your teammates that you don't really
care about them their needs aren't as
important to you so make some time try
to be around and try to be available but
if you have to be at a lot of meetings
as I know some managers and lead EV do
then just let them know that you would
prioritize requests from them to mean
let them know that your priority even if
you can't physically be near them
frequently and then when you do respond
in these circumstances it's really
important that you're open with the
information you're giving most
developers are astute people and they
can tell if someone is holding back
information or just giving them just
enough so that way you leave them alone
and that breeds a lot of distrust right
because it's telling them hey I don't
have confidence in you to give you the
whole story or I don't have time to be
bothered giving you the whole story
so be open try to give until they seem
satisfied with your response and not
necessarily when you think that they
should be satisfied with your response I
know for myself this can be really
difficult if I have a big project
I need to finish or have a lot of
meetings for whatever reason it could be
really easy for me to just want to brush
people off but I found that taking a
little bit of extra time to like
actually communicate effectively with
them goes a long way towards building
better relationships and building them
into better developers because it
transfers knowledge to them and lets
them know that hey I have confidence in
you I trust you to do your job well to
this advice though of being available
and being open I would also not be
encouraging as with praise in the review
process a little bit of encouragement
can go a long way if a junior dev is
coming to you asking questions about how
to implement feature
inter conversation by letting them know
that you're excited to see how it turns
out or if you have to work on a hard
problem with a peer let them know that
you're thankful that they're working on
it with you and investing the time or
maybe you find yourself asking a lot of
questions from a lead developer or
senior engineer and let them know hey
thank you for taking the time to help me
and it's really benefiting me many of us
are expected to do good work and that's
why we have jobs but just because we're
expected to do it doesn't mean it
shouldn't be recognized and encouraged
whenever we see it it really takes a
very small amount of energy to say some
positive words to someone but the amount
of energy that that imparts to the other
person can be really tremendous and
could help them be so much more
productive so to wrap up I want to
mention a quote by the paragon of
Silicon Valley Steve Jobs he says he
once said great things in business are
never done by one person they're done by
a team of people and that last word to
me is super critical to the sentiment
expressed here we're not UI engineers or
senior developers or even employees but
we are human those titles might be part
of how we think about ourselves but
they're not really part of our being
it's just something that we happen to do
so I urge you all to put forth a little
bit of extra effort every day to care
more for your fellow developers your
fellow people and I think you'll be
surprised by how much more effective
your team will become and how much
better people will grow so maybe instead
of focusing on getting [ __ ] done as we
are off to say and
industry we focus on growing people my
hope is that this talk has shown that
being more caring or more empathetic
doesn't require you to completely change
your personality also doesn't require a
lot of fancy process but it does require
you to put yourself in the shoes of your
co-workers and understand what makes
them unique
my hope is that this little bit of extra
effort that we put in will help you
experience a team that grows so much
more than you ever have before
and from that labor from that growing of
other people we can begin to go farther
than we ever have before in both in the
workplace and beyond because there is
really so much more to this life than
just work thank you
[Applause]